BILL DUANE: Good
morning everyone.
Super happy to see you all.
My name is Bill
Duane, and I look
after the well-being learning
programs here at Google.
And we're here today to speak
with a friend and partner, Andy
Puddicombe, from Headspace.
And the intention of today is to
mostly practice, and to try out
a number of different
styles of meditation.
And also to talk a little
bit about meditation itself.
But for the most part,
to actually get our hands
dirty, and get
into the practice.
So I'd like to start
off by introducing Andy.
Andy is the founder
of Headspace,
which is a mindfulness
app that we
use in conjunction with our
in-person sits, and detachment
days and a number of
other meditation programs.
And it's really been
remarkable, it's
been remarkable to get to
know Andy and his team.
And also to get the benefits
of the Headspace app, which
probably some of you guys
have also checked out also.
So in some ways, Andy
could be a Googler, right?
There's a lot of people here
with interesting and weird
backgrounds.
I'm looking at my friend,
Mario, who teaches SAY,
and on the side is a medical
doctor and has a Ph.D.
In neuroscience.
There's many other stories
like that in the audience.
And Andy was a monk.
You know, normally
it's like a technology
founder, monastic background.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: There are
a few clues, though, right?
BILL DUANE: So how long
were you a monk for?
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: So I
trained for about 10 years.
First in the Burmese tradition,
and then for about five years
in the Tibetan tradition.
So I trained first
as a layperson,
then as a novice monk, and
then as a fully ordained monk
in the Tibetan tradition.
BILL DUANE: And then what
drew you into the position
that you're in now?
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: Yes, so
I'd finished my training
at the monastery.
You never really finish it, but
I finished a period of training
at the monastery.
And I'd been sent
away to go and teach
meditation in the
Meditation Center in Moscow,
of all places.
It was as far away as
they could send me.
And I was there and
a lot of ex-pats
used to come along to
the Meditation Center.
And there was one
in particular who
was really keen for me to go
in and work with his staff.
And it was in an oil company.
Again this is in Moscow.
And he d I'd love to have you
in, but dressed like that?
So I was in my robes, and
for all intents and purposes,
for anyone not familiar
with Tibetan Buddhism,
I was basically a
bald guy in a skirt.
So he's all, we're never
going to get you in there,
dressed like that.
And it got me
thinking, you know?
What do I care about?
What am I passionate about?
Am I passionate about
the being a monk,
or passionate about
teaching meditation?
It was a really easy
choice to make, actually.
So when I spoke to my teacher,
and I finished my time
as a monk, and I started working
more in that type of space.
BILL DUANE: Now, I'm curious.
When did you get the time to do
the voice acting with the Geico
gecko commercials?
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: See, I didn't
get this until this morning.
They actually had to take me
through this, this morning.
I said, what?
And even when he
did play it, I was
like, what, that sounds like me?
Really?
BILL DUANE: Wait,
wait, am crazy?
When I first started
listening the Headspace app,
I was like, shit,
that guys sounds just
like the Geico gecko.
Am I alone?
Or is there anyone else?
And I'm sorry if I've
ruined it for you.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE:
So, I don't know
if there's an especially
high adoption rate to Geico
insurance, so I've
been dropping in
throughout take 10,
take 15, take 20.
You will buy our-- no.
BILL DUANE: Subliminal messages.
That's why the app is so
inexpensive for Googlers.
It has subliminal messages
to get you to buy Geico.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE:
Sponsored by Geico.
BILL DUANE: I thought this
might go off the rails,
but I wasn't-- I didn't think
it would quite so quickly,
but fair enough.
So, practice.
I was curious who's
in the room, in terms
of practice experience.
That will sort of help
us guide and curate
what we're doing today.
So who here is brand new?
OK, awesome, welcome, welcome.
Thank you for coming
to a tech talk, even
those who knows what
you thought it might be.
We'll make sure
that this is geared.
And how many people
have a daily practice?
ANDY PUDDICOMBE:
Great, look at that.
BILL DUANE: How
many people would
like to have a daily practice,
but aren't quite there yet?
Thank you for being honest.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: There's many.
BILL DUANE: Super cool.
All right, I think that gives
us a good cross section.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: Great.
Well, I had a teacher who
always used to say to me,
unless you can
improve on silence,
it's better not to
say anything at all.
And I thought about
that for today.
And I thought, it probably
wouldn't be that interesting
if we just sat here
for 90 minutes,
and really didn't
say anything at all.
It's an interesting kind
of balance to strike.
Because we have
to say something.
Right?
I think we can't just come
to meditation and just sit.
For most of us that's
a bit of a struggle.
And even when we
learn to do that,
it then becomes a struggle
to do it every day.
But I do think that
balance is important.
There's so much
chatter around, I
don't know how you
feel about this, Bill.
There's so much
chatter and discussion
around my mindfulness
at the moment,
that we're at kind of risk of
creating so much noise in that,
that we miss out
on the very thing
that we set out to discover
in the first place.
It reminded me of a chef.
When I was much, much
younger working at school I
used to work in the kitchen.
And he was really
kind of a hectic chef.
He used to run around
and make lost of noise.
Even when he was
pretty calm, he was
kind of running around, kind
of really stressing out.
And we'd just be
standing there, cutting
the vegetables, same
old pace every day.
And it was amazing.
He was the only one
running around going,
it's so noisy in here,
it's so hectic in here.
And we'd just be, yes, chef.
And just carry on with
what we were doing.
And there's a
similar kind of risk,
you know we read a
lot about mindfulness,
we talk a lot about it, but
we don't actually do it.
And there's just one more.
There's a little
quote from a teacher
that I remember in
the Tibetan school,
and he was like,
of all the people,
of all those who think
about meditation,
very few people actually begin.
Of those that begin,
very few continue.
And of all those that continue,
very few continue to the end,
whether we see the end
as the end of our life,
or some kind of
lasting peace of mind.
And so Headspace has really
grown out of that one quote.
How do we get people
excited enough to try it?
When you try it, how can we
keep you engaged in some way?
And then how can we make
that a lifelong practice?
So I thought today
we'd look at not just
mindfulness, but a few
different types of meditation.
Because for me, that daily
practice-- mindfulness
is a fantastic way of
introducing meditation
to the West, I think.
And the beauty of it,
it translates so well
into everyday life.
So you have your daily
routine, your daily practice,
your daily sit.
But then you can apply
that to everyday life.
But it doesn't necessarily
have to be the only way
to have your daily sit.
And my own experience-- So
I spent about five years
training quite strictly in
the Burmese school, which
is very, very serious.
And it's all just kind
of straight mindfulness.
And it was wonderful, and it
was an amazing introduction.
But for me personally, I still
felt like it hadn't quite
unlocked all the doors.
I didn't necessary
find the warmth in it
that I'd been looking for.
And I was introduced to
some other techniques,
and that immediately did it.
So it's really important to
recognize we're all different,
and all of us relate to
different types of techniques.
So I though today,
still very down-to-earth
stuff, nothing too
wacky, nothing too crazy.
But just looking at maybe
visualization and reflection
and just to see how
you get on with those.
And these are all
things that are included
as part of Headspace journey,
so this isn't something kind
of out there or
separate from that.
BILL DUANE: Yeah,
really look at this
as trying out
different practices
in the laboratory of
your own experience.
We know the research, the
directionality of the research,
is clear.
That the more you practice
the more benefit that you get.
And we know it's really
hard to practice.
I mean to me, the
dirty little secret
of mindfulness and
meditation is that it works,
and most people don't do it.
Therefore, this group
of people, which
is not only the
people here at Google
thinking about mindfulness, but
our partners outside of Google,
how can we help, how can
we support, how can we
be of service for you to
find a practice that works
for you, so you can do
this thing that we know
will bring benefit for you?
In this case, for this company?
And then for the people who
you meet and in the world,
it all hinges in finding a
practice that works for you
and that you can
do consistently.
So my invitation is to
take some joy in the buffet
you're about to
sample at, and also
feel OK with how this
experience lands with you.
This is an investigation.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: A
meditation buffet.
Never heard of it.
Only at Google.
The stories of your buffets
are out there everywhere.
What I'd like you
to do is to just,
and this is for no
particular reason
other than my own
enjoyment, I'd just
like you to start with just
patting your head, if you can.
OK, now you know
where this is going.
OK, I'd just like you to start
rubbing your stomach, as well.
All right.
Now, if you can continue
that, try to keep it nice
and even, if you
can, patting the head
and rubbing the stomach.
Now at the same time,
I'd like you just
to visualize your
front door at home.
They start to notice how
everything's-- I'm already
starting to see a bit of this
going on, as you visualize.
OK, just come back to
the physical movement
and then visualize
the front door again.
Now to add to that, I'd like you
to just very slowly, quietly,
under your breath, just start
whispering your zip code,
just to yourself.
(WHISPERING) Say it a
little bit louder than that.
OK, and I'll be
back in 90 minutes.
Now so now how many
of you found yourself
thinking about, I
don't know, what
you're doing later in the day?
No one.
So something really
interesting here.
You weren't trying
not to think, you
were simply directing your mind
with a sense of playfulness,
kind of interest, curiosity,
whatever you want to call it.
And actually the mind
was quite focused.
So the temptation
is, when we sit down
to meditate first
thing, right, this
is really kind of
serious, right?
I need clear my mind.
Right, focus.
And of course, the mind
resists against that.
You then start to
think a lot, usually.
OK, so if you can bring that
same sense of playfulness
and ease and lightness
to meditation,
then it can make
a real difference.
So we're going to start off
with just a short exercise.
How many of you have done
Take 10 from Headspace?
Wow, loads of you.
Great, so we're going to start
off with a basic exercise which
brings in a little bit of the
calming aspect, a little bit
of the focus, the clarity
aspect, just as a start.
And we'll then move on
to some visualization
and some reflection, as well.
And I'll just pause
between each one,
just in case you've got
any questions at all.
Anything to add, Bill?
BILL DUANE: Sounds good,
I'm excited for it.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: I'm sure you've
already turned your phone off,
or put them on
silent, but if there
is anyone who wants
to double check,
so you're not sitting there
thinking about whether you
should double check,
you might like to.
And just get yourself
into a position
that feels comfortable for you.
So you can do this either
eyes open or eyes closed.
I'm going to suggest
you do it eyes closed,
but it's just because maybe
a few less distractions.
But it's entirely up
to you and whatever
feels most comfortable.
I'm just going to
step to the side here.
I'd like you to begin by just
looking directly forward,
directly ahead.
Bill, you're on stage.
So just a very, very soft focus.
So you're not staring
at any one thing.
You can see out of your
peripheral vision, either side,
above, below.
And just maintaining
that nice, soft focus.
Just take a couple
big, deep breaths,
breathing in through the nose,
and out through the mouth.
So as you breathe in through
the nose, just a sense
that you're taking in some
fresh air, feeling the chest,
the lungs expanding.
And as you breathe
out through the mouth,
just a sense of the body
softening a little bit.
Just a couple more times,
breathing in through the nose,
and then out through the mouth.
And with the next exhalation,
just gently closing the eyes.
And as soon as you
close the eyes,
you're going to become more
aware of the other senses.
To begin with, I'd like you
to become particularly aware
of the feeling of touch.
The weight of the body
is pressing on the chair.
The souls of the
feet on the floor.
And the hands and the arms
just resting on the legs.
Remember, even at the
beginning, just allowing
thoughts to come and go.
We're just shifting
the attention
to those physical sensations.
We're starting to notice
the space around us,
noticing any sounds.
Noticing any resistance
to any sense.
And then just gently bringing
the attention back to the body.
I'd just like you to gently
scan down through the body now.
Starting at the top of the head,
take the next 30 seconds or so.
Just to scan downwards,
noticing how the body feels.
What feels comfortable,
or feels uncomfortable.
And not thinking
about the feelings,
just noticing the
feelings as you
continue to scan down
towards the toes.
Before shifting the
attention to the breath,
just take a moment, just to
be really clear in your mind
why you're doing what
you're doing right now.
Just a sentence in your mind.
A sense of why you're
doing what you're doing.
And then just letting that
go, bringing the attention
to the breath.
Now you may feel the
breath in your stomach,
in your chest, diaphragm.
If you can't feel
the breath at all,
just gently place your
hand on your stomach.
And just notice, what
does the breath feel like?
Are the breaths long?
Short?
Is it breathing deep or shallow?
And just to help maintain
the focus on that sensation,
if you like, you can
just gently start
to count the breaths
as they pass.
As you feel the rising
sensation, you count one.
Following sensation, two.
Three, then four, just
up to a count of 10.
Just try that a couple
times for right now.
Remember, allowing
thoughts to come and go.
If you do get distracted,
as soon as you realize,
just gently bring the
attention back again.
A rising and falling sensation.
And just for a moment now,
just letting go of any focus.
Letting the mind
be completely free.
So for 10, 15, 20
seconds, just let
it do whatever it wants to do.
Let it think, if
it wants to think.
And then just gently bringing
the attention back once again
to the body.
Starting to notice the physical
sensations again, the weight
of the body, body on the
chair, the feet on the floor,
the weight of the arms.
You starting to notice
the sounds again.
As you just become more aware
of the space around you,
and in your own time,
when you're ready,
you can just gently
open your eyes again.
OK.
And everyone is back with us?
It was suggested, at one
point, that we do this session
immediately after lunch.
Which I thought was
a really bad idea.
Because I think right
now I'd be asking you
all to nudge the person
next to you to wake up.
OK.
So we're just taking a couple of
questions in between each one.
One, as a way of
kind of just clearly
separating each
type of exercise,
but also quite
useful, just to get
some sort of immediate
feedback and comments.
AUDIENCE: First of all, thank
you for the Headspace app.
For me, having kind of a
structured obvious progression
has been a real difference
in whether or not
I could keep it going, versus
searching for YouTube videos
and trying to link
them together.
And I work for YouTube, so
that's saying something.
My question is--
And you're probably
familiar we have a few
other courses in Google,
we have Search Inside Yourself,
and Mindfulness-Based Stress
Reduction.
And as I started taking those
around the same time I started
the Headspace app, I
started having a-ha moments
about why we do certain
things within the progression.
And I was wondering if you
could share some of the goals
or ideas behind the
structuring of it.
Especially in the Take 10,
but I guess the first 15 or 20
of them.
Why we're doing certain things
in the order that we're doing.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: Yeah,
OK, within this exercise,
for example?
AUDIENCE: Specifically
this exercise
would be perfect for the
group, since we all just did it
together.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE:
For sure, for sure.
Happy to.
I think to begin
with, as I said,
very often we come to
meditation it's kind of like,
OK, I need to focus now.
So to begin, when
we first sit down,
the whole idea of this kind
of the spacious kind of focus,
is to remind ourselves
of actually the mind's
a lot bigger than we
often imagine it to be.
So we're just trying to
set the scene and the tone,
if you like.
The deep breaths
just help us kind
of ground ourselves
a little bit.
And by reminding ourselves
of the physical sensations,
we start to feel a little bit
more grounded in the body.
Very often our mind and
body is very separate.
We might sit at our
desk, typing away,
but we're thinking
about something
that happened last week.
Or something that
might happen next week.
So it's kind of bringing
the two together.
There's then the focus element.
By focusing on the
breath-- the breath
is the connector between
the mind and the body.
By focusing on the breath, not
trying to adjust in any way,
we give ourselves a very nice
object, very flexible object,
to focus on.
And the focus bit's important.
But we also need the
relaxation element.
And the interesting bit of
that entire exercise for me,
is the last like 10, 15 seconds.
You know where I say, OK,
now don't try and focus.
So what happened?
That for me was like
the biggest a-ha moment.
I can remember a teacher
of mine saying, OK, right,
I want you to sit
down, close your eyes.
Now I don't want
you to meditate.
It was like something had
short-circuited in my brain.
I didn't know what to do.
I said, what?
And so I sat down, and in
not trying to meditate,
I discovered meditation.
So it's there at the end
really as just a reminder
that we don't need
to focus too much.
There needs to be
focus, but it's
a balance of focus
and relaxation.
When there's a
sense of letting go,
then we generally
find the sweet spot,
where we're able to view
thoughts and emotions
without getting too
involved in them.
So that's really kind of a very
rough outline of that process.
And obviously the
Headspace journey
tries to refine and develop
that process over time.
The biggest bit that
we try to incorporate,
is bringing elements of
compassion, kindness, empathy.
For me that's the
biggest neglected
part of the move of
mindfulness from East to West,
is the lack of heart in it.
It's understandable, it's become
quite clinical in some areas,
and it's appropriate that
it's become clinical.
But for me, that is what
gives it its warmth.
It's what causes the
transformation, the change,
most of all in the
relationships in our lives.
Which I think is very important.
BILL DUANE: I'd agree
with both of those points.
The point at the end
about providing structure,
but not too much structure.
Let's say hypothetically
amongst a group of compulsive
over achievers, there's this
sense of, am I doing it right?
there's this sense of the
moment of realization.
A lot of time it's like, oh,
I'm f-ing this up, right?
My mind was wondering.
So I think there's
that beautiful lesson
of having some
structure and realizing
the benefit of structure,
and then also not grabbing it
on too tight.
And then the compassion
part, plus 100.
I think part of the
reason why, particularly
in the corporate area,
it's a lot easier to speak
about performance and
cognitive ability,
and I think the science
of understanding.
That cognitive part of
it as much in advance.
And now is the time to continue
the efforts to do the research
on compassion and empathy, in
particular Meng helped fund,
with the Dalai Lama--
you know you're
sort of a philanthropic
baller when you're
going in on stuff
with the Dalai Lama.
created a department
at Stanford to study
the science of
compassion, so that when
we take these practices
to the greater community
we can do it standing on our
ground of science and data
in service of something that may
not seem directly scientific,
but is an absolute core part.
So we're certainly--
This idea of practicing
in the spirit of compassion.
And to that end, I'm not
sure if Lindsay got this.
There's a badge reader
over by the door.
The [? gPause ?] program gives
$0.50 for every 20 minutes that
you sit to groups providing
meditation instruction for kids
in jail, and teachers being
taught to teach mindfulness
like this in their classrooms,
and also veterans with PTSD.
So I encourage you
to badge in and have
this count towards that.
And therefore the
practice we're doing here,
in this very awesome,
privileged environment,
can also then create
benefit for the folks.
So this is the way that we're
trying to have these compassion
practices also show
up in the real world.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: That's a
really nice, amazing initiative,
I think, by Google.
And there's something
you can do to impact
the people in your
immediate circle, as well.
On v2, for those of
you that have already
made the transfer--
apologies for any bugs,
I'm aware there
might have a couple.
I heard rumors.
So those of you that have
successfully made the transfer,
there is a reward
mechanic in that now.
But we've tried to flip the
game mechanic on its head.
So you're rewarded for doing
a certain number of days
in a row, and you're then
given free subscription
to give away to your
friends and family.
So it encourages a
sense of altruism,
but it also kind of encourages
your friends and family
to start doing what we all
know is extremely beneficial.
So it's a good thing to
have a look at on that.
What do you reckon?
Do you want to do one
more question, and then
we'll do the next exercise?
Yeah.
There's a mic just
on its way over.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: Got to say,
you're looking man, Andy.
As one bald guy to another.
I assume there was no irony
in calling the app Headspace?
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: I assume there
was no irony involved
in calling the app Headspace?
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: No obvious
irony that I'm aware of.
No, none whatsoever.
AUDIENCE: Silliness aside,
I've derived tremendous benefit
for using the app,
and I naturally
have a fairly
anxious disposition.
I've fought it all my life.
My dad has chronic OCD,
and he visited recently.
And I was like, Dad,
Headspace is dynamite.
Even if you don't
use Headspace, start
meditating on a daily basis.
You are a classic
example of a guy
who would benefit
greatly from it.
And he said, I know.
I said, so Dad, when
are going to do it?
He said, I'm not going to do it.
And I said, why not?
He said, I'm afraid of
what I'm going to find.
How do I-- I mean, you
can't bring a horse to water
and make it drink, but do you
have any suggestions for me
on how I might approach
the conversation.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: Yes,
it's a really good one.
It's definitely a story
I've heard so many times.
People who know they
would benefit from it,
but are fearful of
what they might find.
And often people who aren't even
in that bracket of experiencing
severe patterns of
thought like OCD.
My own experience has
been, spending time
with that individual
and meeting them
where they are, is the
most important thing.
So if they're in
one place-- yeah,
I'm not really
interested in this,
and we're in the other place,
you should really do this,
you should really do
this-- there inevitably
is going to be some tension.
For me it's like a dance.
You go with them.
Where are they going with it?
OK, why don't they
want to do it?
So you go with them, and you
go down that story with them,
and you listen to them
and hear them out.
And what I found very
useful is getting
them to not do meditation.
Get them to say
quietly for 10 seconds.
And see what happens.
And after 10 seconds,
based on experience,
was that terrifying?
And often, 10 seconds
feels kind of manageable.
Doesn't feel too scary,
doesn't feel too threatening.
OK what does 20
seconds feel like?
What does 30 seconds feel like?
I do think with some people
it's about building it up.
And always it's
about experience.
So if you go right back to the
very beginning of the tradition
of these teachings,
it's like try it.
If it works for
you, then try this.
Try that.
If that works, you try this.
So what is the smallest
unit we can get someone
to engage with to experience
that sense of trust
and confidence, so they can
then go on and try the next bit?
And it is always unique
to every person, at least
that's my own experience.
And we can put out an
app like Headspace,
but it is quite
generic by nature.
And so in situations like that,
definitely having a family
member or friend who can
help shape it a little bit,
and help them
experiment with it I
think is a really useful thing.
I don't know.
BILL DUANE: Yeah,
I agree with that.
And I think if
someone doesn't want
to meditate, that's
completely fine.
That was me.
People were just like, you
should really try meditation.
I'd just be like,
forget you, hippy.
Right?
It's clearly in
the same box as--
and I apologize
if there's anybody
who's into this-- like
crystals, and auras.
And I'm a scientist.
I'm an engineer.
That's not for me.
And it wasn't until
I went to a tech talk
on the neuroscience of
emotion, and my own discomfort
and suffering was great
enough where I'm like,
OK, maybe this is for me.
And I think if someone had tried
to force it on me before then,
it would have actually
driven me farther away.
So I think that
saying, not for me,
is a perfectly
acceptable answer.
This is difficult.
This is joyful and rewarding
work, but it's also difficult.
And I think it's
important for people
to make an informed choice
to engage with this practice.
Realizing it's hard.
So I think just saying, not
for them right now, is fine.
And I firmly believe that
a big part of practice
is for the benefit of the people
who have to deal with you.
And I know that a lot of times
the changes in how I show up
and how I am in the world, a lot
of times people will be like,
what happened?
A little disturbed that it's--
What was it like before?
And really they're saying, wow.
It's not like reading about the
neuroscience, it was just like,
man, I really noticed you
just seem a lot happier, more
effective, the parts
of your personality
that most annoy
me are less there.
So working on yourself,
and showing up
in the world as focused, as
compassionate, as generous,
and as a good listener.
These are all the things that
come out of this practice.
Just work on that,
and then that's
the best billboard
for it, I find.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: So shall
we do another exercise?
How many of you have done
virtualization before?
Any kind of visualization?
OK, not so many.
OK, so I'm going to try to theme
the exercises today so they all
have a link between all of them.
The visualization we're
going to do right now
is still kind of body
based, if you like.
And there's a benefit
to that, and I'll
explain why afterwards.
I'm going to ask you
during the visualization
to imagine sunlight.
Now this is really important.
You can see there's nothing
weird or wacky about sunlight.
Imagine bright sunlight,
streaming through the trees,
or whatever it might be.
So if I talk about light
during the exercise,
I'm not talking about a
bright white light or anything
like that.
I'm just talking about sunlight,
just the quality of sunlight.
It's warm, it's
open, it's spacious.
There's something kind
of really useful in that.
BILL DUANE: Any unicorns
in the visualization?
Is the light coming
from the unicorn?
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: I think
unicorn comes in, yeah, it's
about two thirds
of the way through.
But that's OK, I'll
just slip it in there.
It comes right
after the Geico bit.
Is he a lizard or something?
I can't remember what he is.
All right, has anyone struggled
with visualization before?
People who have
tried it, or anyone
here who thinks they
can't visualize?
Because quite often
there are some people.
OK, so if you could just
think back to something,
a pleasant experience
from last weekend.
If you didn't have a pleasant
experience last weekend,
you can go back to the
weekend before then.
Go back as far as you need to.
Maybe it was with
friends, with family.
Just remembering
a nice situation.
Maybe you were outside
having a barbecue,
or out for a walk or something.
Everyone think of something?
Yeah?
OK, all right.
It's that amount
of effort that's
required for visualization.
Just imagining something.
In fact, imagination could be
another word for visualization.
There's no kind of special,
extra thing that's needed.
And often people struggle
with visualization,
because there's a little bit too
much effort that goes into it.
So I'd just like you to do
another thing for me now.
So that's something
you've already done,
so you might think,
yeah, well I'm
remembering that rather
than imagining that.
OK, so just imagine a good
friend of yours standing
there in front of you.
And just get in to
do, I don't know,
jumping jacks or
something like that.
Whenever, you ask them
to do anything they like.
Just get them to do
some physical movement
in front of you.
Everyone imagine that.
Yeah?
OK.
So again, it's something I'm
assuming it hasn't happened,
maybe it did happen
last weekend.
Maybe that's part of the thing.
I don't know.
But I'm assuming it
hasn't, and yet it's
quite easy to turn
you mind towards that.
Just that very kind
of gentle imagination
is really all that's
required here.
So again, I'm going to
lead you through it.
These exercises, I know,
they're quite guided.
There's quite a lot
commentary through it.
We'll talk a little
bit afterwards
about how to yourself
off the commentary.
But to begin with, I think this
is quite useful, especially
if it's a new type of
technical or exercise for you.
So if you'd just like
to set yourself up
in exactly the same way
as you did previously.
You're going to start
the exercise in exactly
the same way.
So still looking directly
ahead of yourself,
not staring at any one
thing in particular.
There's just that
very spacious sense,
being able to see either
side, above and below.
And when you're ready,
when you're comfortable,
just taking those
deep breaths again.
Breathing in through the nose,
and out through the mouth.
We're a little bit easier
this time, as you breathe in,
just a sense of the lungs
expanding as you breathe out,
a sense of the body softening.
Just two or three times.
And then with the
exhalation, just
gently closing the eyes again.
OK, and still taking the
time just to ground the mind,
be aware of the
physical sensations.
The weight of the body
against the chair.
Feet on the floor.
Hands and arms on the legs.
Starting to notice any sounds,
either inside or outside
of the room,
And just bringing the
attention back to the body.
Before we begin
the visualization,
just scanning down
in the same way
as you did before,
without any expectation,
without trying to
change anything.
Just scanning from the
head down to the toes.
If the mind wanders
off, just gently
bring it back again
as you carry on.
And just as before,
just touching
on the breath, just
taking 20, 30 seconds.
Just to notice how the
breath feels in the body.
I'd just like you to
imagine, for a moment,
that directly above
your head there's
a steady flow of warm sunlight,
streaming down into the body.
And just the same way on
a very bright day, you
can see the sun streaming
through the clouds
or the trees.
In just the same
way, streaming down,
flowing down, into the body.
And we're going to imagine as
though this sunlight slowly
fills the body up.
And just notice what
happens as you move along.
So I'd like you to
imagine it, streaming
down through the body, down
the left hand side of the body,
down the left leg
and all the way
down to the foot and the toes.
So it's almost as though
we're filling up a vase.
And you just watch as
the small toes fills up,
and the next, and
the next, next.
Big toe.
And it continues to flow
down, now filling the foot.
Just that very warm,
spacious quality.
Now moving up past the ankle
into the lower half of the leg.
You just feel any tension
melting away, dissolving,
as it moves up past the knee
into the upper half of the leg.
The gentle, steady stream
flowing down through the body.
Now all the way up towards
the hip and the pelvic area.
And before we continue,
just notice the difference
in feeling between your left
and right leg right now.
But it continues to stream down.
This time we go down the right
side, down the right leg,
into the right foot.
Starting with the small
toe, just watching
as each part of
the foot, each toe,
replaced by this very
spacious quality.
Filling up the foot,
past the ankle,
the lower half of the leg.
Just watching as it
continues to travel upwards,
past the knee into the
upper half of the leg,
and just feeling any
tension melting away.
All the way up to the waist.
In just the same way as
with the other exercise,
if the mind wanders, let
it wander, no problem.
But when you realize
it's wandered, just
gently bring the focus back
again to this visualization,
this sense, this feeling
of warmth, spaciousness.
As you watch now as it
begins to fill upwards.
The lower stomach, the lower
back, as though everything just
starts to give
away a little bit.
Upwards towards the diaphragm,
the middle of the back,
and up towards the chest,
in between the shoulders.
Remembering where
that's coming from,
above the head,
still streaming down.
Dissolving any discomfort.
It moves now up towards
the neck and the throat.
Now coming down from above the
head up through the jaw area.
Just feeling
everything dissolve.
Up past the nose, the eyes, all
the way to the top of the head.
And even when you get
the top of the head,
even though the body is now
completely full of sunlight,
it still continues to flow.
And it's as though it just gets
a little bit bigger, a bit more
spacious, going beyond
the confines of the body
into the space around you.
You can either just
sit comfortably,
just for a few more
seconds with that feeling.
Or, if you find it
helpful, you can just
imagine that continuing on
outwards in every direction,
as far as the mind
can imagine it,
and just everyone else
benefiting from that experience
as it goes outwards.
Now as with last time, nothing
really to do at this stage,
just allowing the mind
to expand outwards,
enjoying that sense of
warmth and spaciousness.
And then just gently bringing
the attention back again,
becoming more aware of the body
and the physical sensation.
Still maintaining that
sense of lightness,
that sense of
clarity, but becoming
more aware of the weight
of the body again.
More aware of the
feet on the floor.
Hands on the legs.
Noticing any sounds.
And in your own time, when
you're ready, and just
gently open the eyes again.
OK.
Any thoughts?
I don't mean any thoughts, I'm
sure there were some thoughts.
Anybody have any questions or
anything they liked to share?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Just want
to reiterate what
you said about the Headspace
app being a way of doing it
that I otherwise
wouldn't have done.
I've even tried visualizations
with other sort of people,
and they don't sound
like my sort of people.
Sort of having this
nasally, New England voice.
I don't think it's xenophobia
thing, but maybe, I don't know.
So I really appreciate
checking in with you everyday,
my virtual, mental gym buddy.
I really appreciate that.
Bit when I'm doing
mindfulness, as
with Headspace where we try to
just sit there and be clear,
I can't help but find
that I get bored.
I think MTV ruined
me in that regard.
Whereas visualizations,
I feel like I can,
at least with this
one in particular,
I can just keep going.
And I don't feel like,
oh time is passing,
I should be doing
something else.
I don't have to
battle those thoughts.
So is there a reason
why, the Headspace app,
why you chose to not
go with visualizations?
Because it seems like it's
an easier entry point.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: Yeah,
it's interesting.
I think for some people
it's an easier entry point.
I think not for everyone.
The thing that struck me was
when I went into the Tibetan
tradition, I found there
was so many techniques.
If I looked at it first, before
I went to the Burmese thing,
and there were too
many techniques.
It was like walking into a
shop and being just paralyzed
by choice.
And I was like,
OK, I'm just going
to find something
really simple, actually,
where there's no choice.
And when I went back to
the Tibetan tradition,
I found all these different--
it was really quite rich,
actually.
I know it exists in other
traditions, as well,
but this was my only
experience of it.
And every single one
unlocks something different
for somebody else.
I'm not sure about
the entry point.
I actually think in
the West, particularly,
mindfulness is a
fantastic entry point.
Because it's not threatening.
That one, that exercise we
just did, for some people
I know-- like my
mates in the pub.
They wouldn't be
listening to me rattle
on about on about
beaming sunlight
coming down from the sky.
They'd be like, yeah, just
go and get another drink.
And sharp.
So I think there is
something very down to earth
about the approach
of mindfulness.
And I personally feel if we
can get the language right,
and it's still
transitioning actually,
that we can start to bring in
all of these other techniques
and make them feel part
of our holistic approach
to meditation.
BILL DUANE: And I would
add that even the stuff
that you might not traditionally
think of as meditation,
like yoga, right?
There's a lot of people for whom
they have an existing, maybe
they'll call it
secular yoga, there's
also the opportunity to
apply the same reflective and
contemplative frame
to that activity.
And our friend Gopi here has a
lot of activities around that.
So if you're into
visualization, I
think it's fine to seek
out those resources.
If body movement is a way for
you keeping from being bored,
I think that's another
great way to do it.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: Yeah, I agree.
That direction,
there is definitely
like a visualization, it
tends to have a direction,
so you feel like you're
on a bit of a journey.
And so, for some people, and
sometimes and some situations,
it can feel much easier
to stay with that.
But the boredom bit, that's
a really important bit.
It's quite an exciting,
juicy bit in meditation.
It's underrated, boredom.
Once you get to experience
boredom within meditation,
you're starting
to get somewhere.
And it's a really,
really valuable thing.
I would just say be curious.
Be interested in boredom,
and the something
kind of in that definition.
BILL DUANE: To extend that also,
we spend so much of our time
desperately avoiding boredom.
You know that urge
to pull the phone out
in the elevator,
other places, right?
To me, it's really
interesting to note boredom.
What's it like to be bored?
It's almost like needing
to scratch an itch.
It feels weird to disobey
when you're bored.
So I think it's a
great area to get
curious about, because
if you can have
some mastery over that
compulsion to occupy boredom,
it unlocks a whole
bunch of other things.
So we can either be
like, oh-- And as
usual there's a balance
to be had, right?
Sometimes If I'm really
bored, it's just tough to sit.
You just want to get up.
So then you provide yourself
with a little more stimulation
so you can stay in the game.
And sometimes it's
[? interesting ?]
to get curious about
what's it like to be bored.
What's my relationship
with being bored?
For me personally, why
do I dislike it so much?
And there's a lot of the
usual thing of examining
a relationship to our
compulsive behaviors,
and boredom is a
huge field for that.
For me at least.
AUDIENCE: My question
is, so I'm really
enjoying the guided aspect
of the Headspace app,
and I noticed the amounts of
silent time increase over time,
and that's great.
I'm just wondering if you view
the guided stuff as a means
to an end, where
ultimately we're
aiming for completely
silent meditation?
Or is that just a fine way
to continue, indefinitely,
having guided meditations?
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: I
would like to think
that I'm not making
the decision for you,
that ultimately you
make the decision what
works best for you, and
what you find most helpful.
I think it's something we
took quite a lot of-- Have
you played around with v2 yet?
Have you had a look?
OK.
So you'll see in v2, we've
included a whole series
of unguided meditations
in the single section.
So if you do decide,
wow, I've just
had enough of that bald
guy, there is somewhere
to go within the app where
you can listen to silence.
Amazing.
BILL DUANE: Like
the John Cage song?
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: Genius.
No, there's a
little gentle intro.
Or, if you haven't
sat in silence before,
and it comes back to not
really knowing what to expect,
or being fearful, perhaps,
of what might come,
there's another whole section
in there called Headspace Pro.
I didn't come up with
a name, by the way.
And that's really about how do
you learn to sit in silence?
So in the first 10 days,
there's an introduction
to the type of
obstacles that tend
to arise when you sit
in silence, so you
know what to expect.
As you move into the
second lot of 10 days,
slowly I'm weaning you off,
and the periods of silence
are getting bigger and bigger.
And then it's starting to
go into a bit more depth
at the beginning and
at the end, looking
at the obstacles that arise.
But the meditation itself, the
exercise itself, is in silence.
So that would be my
preference, where we're still
getting some contacts
and some teaching,
but we're learning to sit
and to enjoy the silence.
Because we get to listen to
other people all the time.
BILL DUANE: I think it's
important to not hold the idea
that you graduate beyond
counting, or labeling,
or listening.
Because something that
I find difficult is,
when I first started
sitting, was this idea
of coming back to square one.
That felt like losing to me.
That felt like screwing it up,
because you had this progress
and now you're
back to square one.
Whereas in coming
back to square one
is actually the heart
of the practice.
And sometimes,
even despite having
sat for a fair amount of
time, guided meditations
are really good.
Labeling, sometimes even
labeling out loud for me,
is really useful
during a time of storm.
So it's not something
you graduate from,
it's just that you
add other options.
And silence becomes
one of those options.
There's not a damn thing wrong
with counting, or labeling,
or listening to a guided
meditation, either.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: Yeah, and
I really believe that, just
in terms of over time, whether
we're talking about effort,
or whatever it is.
It's always different.
Every time.
If our practice is
honest and open,
and every time we
sit down, and we're
simply present with
the mind as it is,
every single day
will be different.
And it will be based on
what we've just come from,
maybe what we're going to, and
all these other kind of things.
So we're always just
a little bit this way,
a little bit that way.
Maybe adding a bit of this,
maybe taking a bit of that
away.
Foot on the gas,
foot off the gas,
and just finding that spot.
And that's always
the case, I think.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
there is any tip or any way
to fight physical
uncomfort or pain.
I did Take 10 just
fine, sitting down.
But the transition between
Take 10 and Take 15,
I find myself thinking at
the end, OK, I'm hurting,
I'm hurting.
And if I shift, I basically
go back to square one.
So I'm not sure if
I'll be the strength
to do Take 15, Take
20, and go beyond that.
Or if I should go back
and stick to Take 10.
I've tried sitting in
different positions,
and so far it's been
the same outcome.
So I was thinking if
there's any tip for that?
ANDY PUDDICOMBE:
OK, there's actually
some great tips in Take 20,
but that's a terrible thing
to suggest.
As soon as you said it,
well that's what Take 20 is.
It's all about settling into
discomfort, and how approach it
and how to deal with it.
But don't worry, I'm not
going to suggest that.
Does as the pain
continue after you get up
and you finish you meditation?
OK, so that's a really
important point.
So if it does, then there maybe
something about your sitting,
or there maybe something a
bit more structural there,
and you might want
to get that seen to,
or speak to someone about it.
If it doesn't, there are certain
kind of pains and discomfort
which arise during meditation.
And if you're really
cautious about this,
and if you are at all
concerned, of course
you need to see your doctor.
It's really important.
But my only experience
has been, and I
know the experience of many
friends is, when we sit,
sometimes we
experience discomfort.
And there can be a
temptation or tendency
to really want to move
away from that discomfort.
It's like we just
can't bear it anymore.
But as long as
it's not pain which
is causing us
further discomfort,
there is some benefit
sometimes to sitting with that,
and being interested in it.
Again, it's a bit like
the boredom thing.
Can we step back from it
enough to step out of that loop
where it hurts, physically,
and therefore our mind is
like, oh, that really hurts.
And therefore it gets
a bit more tense.
And then the mind goes,
oh, now it really hurts,
I've got to stop,
I've got to stop.
OK, if we can step out
of that circle and go,
OK, that's interesting.
What is that?
How does that feel?
What is the discomfort?
Is the discomfort either a heavy
dull feeling, is it a sharp,
stabbing feeling?
Start to be more interested
in the feeling itself.
And very often when we
do that, the feeling
starts to change and shift,
and our relationship to it
changes, as well.
So you might just want to have
a play with that, and just see.
But if not, send
us in an e-mail,
put it as a title
heading, Andy's Answers.
And we've got a little
section, because that
would make a really nice
blog thing, as well.
So happy to add
some more to that.
BILL DUANE: And it's
always a balance
between engaging with
the difficult to be
curious about it, and self care.
I really believe
everything that Andy said,
and I really had some
interesting experiences
with instead of doing the
automatic thing, which is ow,
stop it.
More like, what's my
relationship to ow?
And then you actually build
up a much greater sense
of possible responses, other
than make it stop right now.
But sometimes we don't
have that available to us.
And it's important not to
turn this into an iron man.
Like grrrrr, oh, I hurt
so much, this is-- No.
We started off with saying that
meditation provides benefit,
and a lot of people don't do it.
And if you set up
a situation where
it's so unpleasant
for you-- So I
would say that it's important
to challenge yourself,
but also to have a sense of
balance of the challenge.
If you find yourself not
wanting to sit because it's
going to be painful, you're
probably veering more
towards the overly
challenge. side.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: I would say so.
And just as on
from that as well,
I personally, I don't
have a problem--
I know some meditation
teachers who
don't like the idea of lying
down or anything like that.
Meditation was
taught traditionally
in four different
postures, and one of them
was lying, actually.
If you do lie, try and do
it in a way that you're not
setting yourself up
for sleep, because it
is very easy to
drift towards sleep.
So lie on a soft mat,
but on a firm surface.
Have the knees
bent at 90 degrees,
so you don't hurt
your lower back.
Feet flat on the floor.
And a very thin pillow
under your head.
And see how you go, as well.
So I think you can be confident
in experimenting, a little bit.
BILL DUANE: And even on long,
multi-day silent retreats,
there will always
be a few people
for whom that's their posture.
And that's totally fine.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: Cool.
I know there's a
couple more questions.
Have we got time for
one more quick exercise?
BILL DUANE: Why don't
we do a quick exercise,
and then also we have
the Dory questions.
I want to make sure
particularly for the folks
on video conference,
and for the folks here.
Let's do an exercise, then
we'll do some more questions.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE:
OK, we're just going
to do a really quick,
not really quick.
Not a hurried meditation.
We're going to do
a short excise.
It's reflection.
Anyone done this type
of exercise before?
It's where you're
asking a question,
but you're not
trying to answer it.
Which is a challenge
for most people.
But it's a really
interesting challenge.
And it's quite an exciting
space to get into, just
generally in life.
Not always trying to use the
rational intellectual mind
to try and answer stuff.
So it's an excise I've
found really helpful.
It was described
to me a bit like,
we help create the
conditions, a framework,
for a still pool of water.
And then we just
drop the question,
and we just sit back and watch.
Maybe something pops
up, maybe it doesn't.
No answer is OK.
We're not necessarily
looking for an answer,
we're just watching
to see what happens.
Sometimes it will
come as a feeling,
sometimes it will
come as a thought.
It's OK.
I'll talk you
through the exercise.
But there's just one
little bit about this.
And because the
intellectual mind always
wants to take over
the whole time,
it's a really important thing.
There's a guy that
came along to-- I
used to work at a
clinic in London--
and we were doing this exercise.
And I said, OK, I can't remember
what the question was exactly,
it was something to the effect
of, what would you miss most
if you weren't around anymore?
Now we did the
exercise together.
And afterwards, I
said OK, how was it?
And he told me.
And he said, but I feel
really a bit uncomfortable.
Do you mind if I tell you?
I said, well you don't have
to tell me what it was.
And he said, no, I want
to tell you what it was.
He said, look, you know
I have an amazing wife,
I have amazing kids,
I've got a brilliant job,
I've got my business.
My life's incredible.
He said but, honestly the
thing that about the feeling
of what I'd miss most, is
my morning cup of coffee.
And so he said, I really
kind of struggled with this.
I spent most of the rest of the
meditation thinking, oh, shoot.
My wife?
My kids?
Really?
So he felt really
guilty about it.
There are no judgments
on what comes up.
There is no right or wrong.
And actually when
we talked about it,
it was really interesting
because his morning
cup of coffee was his moment.
His wife was still in bed
asleep, he got up very early.
He didn't have to communicate,
talk with anybody.
The kids were still sleeping.
He hadn't yet got
in to his work.
And he had those 10
minutes on his own
where he would just smell
the coffee, taste it.
It was kind of like a little
mini mindfulness thing.
He didn't even know
he was doing it.
And yet, it was
that feeling-- when
he asked that question--
it was that feeling which
had arisen in him.
And that's what
gave the feeling.
This is more about
feeling than thought.
So don't think that
has to be like a,
oh yes, I would miss
my mother-in-law.
Or whatever it is.
OK?
It doesn't have to
be like that, OK?
It can just be
perhaps a feeling.
So we'll lean in that direction.
We're going to set up
in just the same way,
so take a moment
to get comfortable.
If you've already done
a couple of-- I normally
spend a little bit longer
on the set-up to this.
I know I'm conscious we
don't have lots of time
as we've just done a
couple of exercises.
We'll just move
through it steadily.
But you already know the
beginning part of this,
of course, which is just
getting yourself comfortable,
eyes open, nice soft gaze.
And just taking just
two or three nice big,
deep breaths where you
breathe in through the nose,
and out through the mouth.
And on the next exhalation,
just gently closing the eyes.
You're already conscious,
aware, in touch
with those feelings of the
body on the chair, feet
on the floor, hands on the legs.
We're already starting
to notice the sounds.
Now as you just turn
the attention inwards
and begin to scan once more.
Just take 20, 30 seconds just
scanning down through the body.
Maybe it feels the
same as before,
perhaps different this time.
Just scanning down
towards the toes.
As you scan downwards,
just starting
to become more aware of the
breath and that movement
of the breath again.
Just pausing to notice the
breath, if only for 20,
30 seconds.
Now just settling
the mind in that way.
And I'd just like you to
ask yourself that question.
The one we just used,
in the second person.
Now who or what would
you miss the most
if you were no longer around?
And we just put the
question out there.
Perhaps something
immediately comes to mind.
If they're thoughts, just
let the thoughts bubble up,
that's fine.
If it's a feeling that arises,
we just sit with that feeling.
Feel present with that
movement of the breath.
If nothing comes up,
that's fine, too.
We can just come back to the
breath again for a moment,
staying with that sensation.
And then if no particular
feeling arose the first time
around, without
forcing it, just gently
asking that same question again.
Who or what would
you miss the most
if you were no longer around?
And this exercise is about
the feeling, rather than
any particular idea or thought.
It's almost as though
we're watching the breath,
but the breath is flavored
with a particular feeling.
And we just stay with that,
not wanting the failing
to continue, not wanting to end.
But just watching it as
It arises and falls away.
And if there's no feeling
whatsoever, that's OK, too.
Just staying with the breath.
And then typically
in these exercises,
we work through a number
of different questions.
But for today, I'd just like you
to gently bring your attention
back once again.
The body to the
physical sensations,
back to that feeling
of weight on the chair,
feet on the floor,
hands on the legs.
And in your own time,
when you're ready,
you can just gently
open your eyes again.
It's always a
tricky balance when
you want to do a
meditation excise,
but there's not a lot of time.
Didn't want to try and
squeeze too much in there,
but hopefully enough
to give you a flavor.
So typically there are
four, in an exercise
like that, there'd
be four questions.
And we'd work through
one after another.
If you do more of
the Headspace packs,
you'll come across that
exercise quite a lot.
It's used a lot within the
Tibetan tradition I trained in.
And it's really interesting.
One letting go is, I
say, is that ability
to-- of that instinct,
that impulse,
to always try and
rationally work it out.
Instead getting in touch
with feeling and instinct
and intuition.
Really, really
valuable for that.
But the kind of
questions that arise,
or the feeling that arises,
is often very surprising.
In my own experience,
and the feedback
from people that use it, is
that they're often taken aback,
and they never even
knew they felt that way
about the question being asked.
So something to have a look at.
But Bill, I know you wanted
to go through some questions
before we wrap things up.
BILL DUANE: Yeah, just a
quick few ones from the Dory.
The first one was
concerning interleaving
different kinds of practice.
In other words, so you have
the skills and stuff that's
coming from Headspace,
and then someone
had attended a
[INAUDIBLE] retreat,
was the particular one.
So how can people combine
different practices
from where they are?
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: Did you
have any thoughts yourself
that you'd like to share first?
BILL DUANE: No, curious.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: OK.
My only experience has been
that when-- it's important
that we stay with a
particular practice
for a defined period of time.
It's OK to do lots of
different practices,
but as much as possible,
we need to stay
with a defined practice.
And that can be as
little as 10 days.
But the reason I say
that is, otherwise
it can become a little
bit pick and and mix.
And it's like you're
doing an exercise,
and maybe it becomes difficult.
So it's, oh, that exercise
really isn't for me.
I'll do a different one.
And then we get into
this thing, where
we're always jumping around.
And we don't really
get the benefit
from actually staying
with that, and learning
through that process.
Because the difficulties
and obstacles,
they are the learning process.
So I would just encourage you
as much as possible-- Maybe you
have your Headspace time
each day where you check in.
And that's in a way
compartmentalized
as an exercise, but you
feel the mindfulness
feeds into your everyday life.
And equally isn't so
different, actually,
from the community sittings
that you might have.
But definitely in
terms of techniques,
I would try to stay with them.
And that's why the
packs are designed
as they are, for
10 days or 30 days,
so that you do stay with that.
BILL DUANE: The
next one is, I've
been trying to use Headspace
for a few months now.
I'm currently in
the 15 days series,
but find myself spending a lot
of days without practicing.
Better to go back to the
beginning, or picking up
where I left off?
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: OK.
This is a really good one,
because everyone falls off
to the meditation wagon.
It happens to us all.
So how to get back on.
General rule of thumb, for
me at least with the app
is, if you've missed more
than a couple of days,
I recommend going back to
the start of the series
that you're on.
I don't mean like on a 40-day
series, you go back to day one.
It's split into 10-day chunks.
So if you've missed
more than a few days,
let's say for more
than five days,
I would go back to
day one of that part.
So you pick up the
sense of continuity,
the sense of teaching
that goes along with it.
If you've missed more
than a couple of weeks,
so we go back to the start,
day one, of that series.
And if you've had a
really long time out,
just to ease yourself back
in, go back to Take 10.
As Bill said earlier, there
is no regression here.
Going back to the start doesn't
mean you're going backwards.
It just means that you're
finding what works best for you
at that particular time.
So don't be shy
about going back.
And I've met some
people who they've
been doing the Headspace
app for a couple of years,
and I met some just
recently, and they said,
oh I'm still on Take 20.
And I said, oh, do you
miss a lot of days?
They're like, no,
never missed a day.
So I was doing the math,
and my math is really bad,
but I'm like, hang on.
That's 45 days, two years--
And she said, oh, I just
didn't want to move on until
I'd absolutely perfected it.
So each to their own.
BILL DUANE: So to wrap up--
and we can hang around here
for a little bit
for questions, but I
want to respect people
who have places to go to,
is the last note we wanted
to sound was an encouragement
to keep going, to
do this practice.
As Andy was talking
about in the beginning,
you don't get the
benefit, and the people
around you in your community
doesn't get the benefit,
from talking about practice,
but from actually practicing.
So our encouragement,
our hope for you guys,
is that this is sort of a
push into making a practice
commitment for yourself
with whatever works for you.
I think Andy was recommending
that the Headspace app,
if you're new to it,
committing to do Take 10.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE:
Absolutely, yeah.
10 minutes a day for 10 days.
If you're completely
new to Headspace.
That feels to me like a really
achievable challenge, or goal
for us all, if you like.
And if you're
already doing it, OK.
Commit to a pact, a 30-day pact.
Have a look-through.
See what calls out
to you, right now.
And see how you can establish
that daily practice.
Bill, I know I mentioned just
briefly earlier, but I do
think that the buddy system
within v2, I'm really
hoping that will
help people engage.
If you've got close
friends or family,
and you can let them know,
you can just e-mail them.
There's a little thing on the
app, as long as they agree,
do they want to buddy up, you
can see each other's progress.
And you can give them a
call and say, how amazing.
I've just seeing you've
done 10 days in a row.
Just want to say well done.
You've inspired me
to do the same thing.
That kind of thing makes
a massive difference,
it really does.
BILL DUANE: And
outside of the app,
there is also daily
sits that are now in 26?
28 locations.
That's pretty amazing.
So those are available
for you to be
in meet space with other
practitioners here.
There's also a
detachment day coming up
this weekend that
still has space.
OK.
And then one on August 3rd.
So that's an entire day
of this sort of thing,
with a secular sort of retreat.
So [INAUDIBLE] go check out
those out in [? gPause ?].
And I think that's about it.
Thank you so much.
ANDY PUDDICOMBE: Thanks so much
for giving up your time, guys.
Thank you.